you know the quality has always have to
be bumped up right I'm always trying to
make sure more quality more quality more
quality you know most actors are just
sitting around waiting for somebody to
say hey you want to be in my movie so I
don't like that play hard man that's the
values we give them play hard all my
records are necessary records all my
hounds are necessary now the beauty of
Straight Outta Compton is not that some
Academy members get it you know cuz they
would get anything you throw in front of
the store I was in bed whoa the question
is are we rock and roll I mean Jonah
Hill and Channing Tatum when they piss
you off he's an American rapper record
producer actor and film producer he
began his career as a member of the hip
hop group CIA and later joined the
seminal rap group NWA he's noted as a
proficient lyricist and storyteller and
regarded as a brutally honest rapper
he's ice cube and here's my take on his
top ten rules for success rule number
one is my personal favorite but I'm
curious to find out which one you guys
like most what is the key to your
success you think cuz you've had a lot
of wins man a lot of talk a lot of wins
um you know I guess respecting what I'm
doing more than getting a win you know I
mean I love to work I love to actually
get in there and create and make some
good take something out the back of my
mind and give it a physical form and let
people enjoy it is really what I get off
on so to do that to be in that mix you
know the quality has always have to be
bumped up right I'm always trying to
make sure more quality more quality more
quality you know throughout the whole
project I'm the king of quality control
are you really yes and I'm doing my
career my way um you know being able to
put together your own movies is a
blessing you know most actors are just
sitting around waiting for somebody just
hey you wanna be in my movie so I don't
like that I would I wouldn't be acting
if I was just sitting around so I love
producing I love writing and just making
sure it happened you got to be proactive
play hard man that's the values we give
them play hard and amen be yourself you
know in this world when when everybody
wants you to be you know the conform
that is conformed to that and my my
whole thing is be yourself man you know
everybody's individual we all got
different fingerprints different DNA
young man we should we should just show
how different we are man just be
yourself the message is you know to me
only as good as the person delivering so
you know the thing is I want to evolve
to the point where people are here and
you know I mean I don't want to evolve
past the point of people hearing but I
gotta say and my message in the end
whatever particular record you listening
to cook all my records are message
driven records all my hounds are message
driven out
I wouldn't I wouldn't call I am the West
a message driven out I would call raw
footage of message driven out so it
depends on how I feel but uh I think you
know I just don't want to involve past
people hear what I got to say cuz you
know to me that that's not evolving
that's dissolve you know so it's really
all about making sure people are hearing
so you got to do what you got to do in
this climate to make sure you heard the
beauty of Straight Outta Compton is not
that some Academy members get it you
know cuz they would get anything you
throw in front of them they don't know
if this is authentic or not right it's
the hardcore fans you know I mean it's
the core fans are the ones who let you
know if you got it right when they say
man you took me back to 87 and I felt
like man I could smell you know the wind
yeah you know gonna do weed I went for
the week so I'm good that's good but you
knows like that's that's what it's all
about yeah it's all about the core
friends and making sure they satisfied
and then the fans the French fans they
gotta get in with a fit in with me you
know I mean they just got to get in
where they fit in I'm not gonna cater
too much to a French fan as much as a
core fan that's probably the Kittitas
success right there to at least one of
them is just like focuses on which yeah
I'm not reaching cuz you reach so far
for that new fan and you come attach
your needs yourself via the korfin we
said you're about to witness the
strength of Street knowledge meaning you
are about to witness you know a
knowledge coming off the streets or out
the streets that you may not have ever
witnessed before we just wanted to be
real we just wanted to be honest Street
knowledge is a term to me
it means letting the streets know what
the government politics police whatever
authority figures are are doing up to
exposing them and also it letting who if
the politicians are listening letting
them know what the streets think and how
things are going and hopefully there's
some understanding that could be made in
all this and you gotta clean up effort
so you say you can no sir world to run
make your life better you gotta make
your life better you gotta bring in
bridge you got to do that work this hard
work doing everything that we do
nothing's easy not even for a rapper
movie whatever you want to do it it's
all hard and it's time to I don't want
to get up and I don't want to do it but
I've got to do it because this is my
life and you gotta make those choices
and you know like I said and I mean in
my little spiel right here there's 24
hours in the back you can do whatever
you want with whatever you want you can
waste them or you can do something
that's gonna help the life because you
will grow up everybody here will grow up
and you will have to deal with all the
problems that all wrong people around
you are telling you that you're gonna
have to deal with
there's no fairytale with no luck it's
hard out there
therefore whatever's on their mind rated
choice on the second side yeah you know
but uh it just comes man did something
come to flavor because it just this one
this one of them slow slow flows email
to everybody again so yeah so a lot of
people not play before many not hours
videos like who was that you know I was
like yo that's me is that always got to
get people what they all expect the
question is are we rock and roll and I
say you goddamn right we rock and roll
see rock and roll is not an instrument
rock and roll is not even a style of
music rock and roll is a spirit it's a
spirit it's been going since the blues
jazz bebop soul R&B rock and roll heavy
metal punk rock and yes
and what connects us all is that spirit
that's what connects us all that spirit
rock and roll is not conforming to the
people who came before you but creating
your own path
in music and in life that is rock and
roll and that is us
so
rock and roll is not conforming rock and
roll's
outside the box and rock and roll is NWA
I want to thank everybody who helped
induct us into the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame and I just want to tell the world
damn that was dope okay you are very
good at seeming angry I don't know if
you are angry in general but in the
movies in 21 and 28 Jump Street you're
disgusted with I mean Jonah Hill and
Channing Tatum when they piss you off so
I thought it would be fun if I gave you
I give you some lines now these are not
lines that you would not classify these
lines as your typical like kind of angry
guy lines in fact they're quite the
opposite of that okay and I'll read them
to you and if you act them back to me in
your own inimitable way okay okay I want
to do that all right say these as
angrily as you can lavender body wash
makes my pores tingle
lavender body wash make my pores tingle
there's nothing better on a gloomy day
than a good book a warm blanket and a
creamy pumpkin bisque man is not better
on a gloomy day then a warm well was a
good blanket a warm blood man
give you some damn pumpkin bris
you know I went to the LA Unified School
District I read that you know what you
did it well
alright alright here's another one for
you I want to love like the love in the
notebook a love that splits the sky I
want to love like the love in a notebook
oneness with the sky
is wonderful and this is great for young
actors as well it's an exercise all
right one more you ready let's do it
OMG did you do something new with your
hair I love it
oMG did you do something with so hair
love
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Marcel Williams asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Ice
Cube's top ten rules have the biggest
impact on you and why leave in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon